So, you think you know a lot about movies?
You can recite every line from Jaws, you know
who composed the music for the Matrix Trilogy
and you know which year every Back to the
Future movie was released?That's impressive,
but what about those lesser known facts from
behind the scenes?
Some facts about movies that you might not
know will undoubtedly take you by surprise
- and that's what this video is all about.Here
are twenty shocking movies facts that you
won't believe are true...
Captain America: Civil War
One day prior to filming a fight scene with
Robert Downey, Jr. in Captain America: Civil
War, Sebastian Stan sent the Iron Man star
a text message saying"Looking forward to our
scene tomorrow Robert!"
Attached to the message was a video of Stan
doing intense bicep curls in front of the
decapitated head of an Iron Man suit.
The Wizard of Oz
One of the stars of the classic movie The
Wizard of Oz was undoubtedly the little dog,
Toto.
However, it's still pretty shocking that Terry
- the female Cairn Terrier who played Toto
- was paid more per week than the midget actors
who played the Munchkins.
Terry received $125 per week, the Munchkin
actors received a mere $50.
Sleeping Beauty
Although Sleeping Beauty - also known as Princess
Aurora - is the titular character in this
classic Disney movie, she actually only has
eighteen minutes of screen time and eighteen
lines of dialogue.
That's the shortest amount of screen time
for any titular Disney character, and the
second quietest of any apart from Dumbo.
Psycho
Alfred Hitchcock's classic psychological horror
Psycho was the first movie to show a flushing
toilet on film.
The flushing of a toilet had previously been
seen as taboo and was almost as shocking for
audiences to see as the infamous shower scene.
Night of the Living Dead
George A. Romero's Night of the Living Dead
is a classic cult horror movie that truly
started the zombie genre way back in 1968.
You may find it hard to believe, therefore,
that the word "zombie" isn't actually used
in the movie at any point.
Star Wars
Star Wars is one of the most iconic movies
in cinema history - and it gave the world
one of the most iconic villains in movie history
in Darth Vader.
But would you believe that he only had twelve
minutes of screen time in the original movie?
That really is testament to the impact he
had.
Monty Python and the Holy Grail
Monty Python and the Holy Grail is undeniably
one of the greatest comedy movies of all time,
and one of its most memorable scenes involved
using coconuts to mimick the sound of horses
trotting.
This scene was actually filmed out of necessity,
because the movie's production team couldn't
afford to use real horses!
Halloween
The terrifying mask worn by Michael Myers
in John Carpenter's Halloween has become one
of the most iconic props in horror movie history.
Therefore, its origins may surprise you.
It's actually a Captain Kirk mask, modelled
on William Shatner himself, painted white.
Not so scary now, huh?
The Terminator
Although the Terminator character is now synonymous
with Arnold Schwarzenegger, studio executives
originally wanted retired footballer O.J.
Simpson to take on the role as the titular
cyborg.
However, director James Cameron intervened
because he thought Simpson was "too nice"
to be taken seriously as the character.
If only he knew...
A Nightmare on Elm Street
The terrifying A Nightmare on Elm Street may
seem like it couldn't possibly be based on
a true story, but it actually was.
Wes Craven based the movie on a real life
story about a traumatised young boy who had
survived the Killing Fields in Cambodia.
The boy refused to sleep and, when he finally
nodded off, he died screaming in the middle
of a nightmare.
Die Hard
Bruce Willis has famously made John McClane
one of the most iconic action heroes of all
time - but the leading man of Die Hard could
have been played by a very different actor.
Due to complicated contractual obligations,
the part had to be offered to Frank Sinatra
first.
Given that the crooner was 73 at the time,
it was definitely a relief that he turned
the role down.
Jurassic Park
The special effects in Steven Spielberg's
brilliant Jurassic Park were revolutionary,
but one of the iconic sounds in the movie
was generated in a very simple manner.
The T-Rex's monstrous roar was a combination
of a baby elephant’s squeal, an alligator’s
gurgling, and a tiger’s snarl, while its
breath was the sound of air escaping a whale’s
blowhole.
The Lion King
The Lion King is an iconic Disney movie that
was undoubtedly made even better by the brilliant
music of Sir Elton John.
However, the British superstar wasn't even
the first choice to write and perform the
soundtrack.
Swedish pop group ABBA were actually asked
first, but one of their members - Benny Andersson
- was unavailable at the time.
Toy Story
Toy Story is arguably the greatest animated
movie of all time - and it forms part of what
is arguably the greatest movie trilogy of
all time - but it almost didn't exist in the
form that we know it.
It was originally conceived as a half-hour
Christmas special.
Thank goodness Disney ultimately decided to
make it a full movie!
The Machinist
When it comes to dedication to a role, very
few actors can match Christian Bale - and
this was never more evident than in The Machinist.
In order to portray an emaciated insomniac,
Bale lost an astonishing 63 pounds.
To do this, his diet consisted of nothing
more than one apple and a single can of tuna
fish every day.
The Dark Knight
In The Dark Knight, Michael Caine was supposed
to have lines in the scene where the Joker
crashes Bruce Wayne's fundraising party for
Harvey Dent.
But Caine was so shocked at seeing Heath Ledger
in character for the first time that he forgot
to speak.
Frozen
When you consider how prominent female characters
are in Disney movies, it may come as something
of a surprise to learn that 2013's Frozen
was the first animated Disney production to
feature a female director.
Jennifer Lee holds the honour of being the
first woman to helm such a movie - and even
she did it in a joint effort with the very
male Chris Buck.
Zootopia
In Disney's hugely successful animated offering
Zootopia, pop star Shakira was one of many
huge stars to voice a character - in her case,
a pop star named Gazelle.
When Shakira saw early designs of the character,
she thought it was too skinny and personally
requested that it was "meatier" with bigger
hips!
How very refreshing!
Independence Day: Resurgence
The sequel to 1996's Independence Day will
be released this summer and it will go ahead
without the previous movie's leading man,
Will Smith.
However, the original plan was for Smith to
reprise his role as Captain Steven Hiller.
Unfortunately, the Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
star demanded a staggering $50 million to
return, resulting in his character being killed
off instead.
Suicide Squad
Due to the dark and tormenting nature of the
upcoming Suicide Squad movie - and, in particular,
thanks to the disturbing behaviour of Jared
Leto as The Joker on the movie's set - an
on-set therapist was hired in order to keep
the all-star cast grounded and sane.
Thanks for watching our list of 20 shocking
movie facts you won't believe are true.
Did you know about any of these?
Which other great movie facts do you know
of?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.